vous avez vécu plus que je ne peux
l'imaginer nous savez ce que c'est que
de vivre éternellement votre immortalité
a fait de vous le plus grand soldat de
la hache et la croix dans la guerre
entre notre monde
le suivant depuis toujours
j'attendais de pouvoir vous aider tu
veux arrêter là non je veux une
augmentation
tu es une rudesse des rêves
sortez
que tu me conduisent dans le monde des
rêves
six ans meurent là-bas
on meurt ici
réveillez vous vous êtes tombé dans
l'ariège
sorcières les plus redoutables que le
monde ait jamais connu sont venus pour
nous anéantir ça a commencé
une sorcière pour apache ah c'est
l'essentiel
alors là tu n'es pas de qualifier pour
ce qui va suivre